sur ma chaîne depuis quelques mois
maintenant j'ai beaucoup abordé la
question du vaccin ou du pass sanitaires
parfois peut-être trop pour différentes
raisons ce un sujet qui m'a tenu à coeur
peut-être à cause de son aspect
scientifique sont aspects sociétal mais
aussi son aspect psychologique
dans cette vidéo un petit peu à la benne
nevers ou bien encore hugo décrypter à
nice rallye j'ai voulu vous donner la
parole en écoutant les messages vocaux
que vous m'avez laissé sur instagram
savoir comment vous vous avez vécu tout
ça personnellement mais aussi au sein de
vos communautés que ce soit vos amis ou
votre famille
comprendre que vous n'êtes pas seuls à
avoir ces problèmes si particulier
salut bas du coup je veux raconter
comment je vais que le colline moi je
suis pas vacciné mais c'est pas la
question parce que dans ma famille à des
personnes qui sont vaccinées et d'autres
qui le sont pas et donc c'est pas du
tout je suis à fond non axe un
jeu pas du tout y a pas de conspiration
il n'y a pas de rien du tout mais mais
j'ai fait l'expérience ce soit dans ma
famille ou dans mes cercles d'amis
bain de l'expérience d'être une personne
non vaccinés est en fait ne pas avoir
mon mot à dire dans les discussions on
fait passer les personnes qui ne sont
pas vaccinés pour pour des égoïstes pour
des pour des personnes qui n'ont pas
conscience pas d'éthique je trouve ça
vraiment vraiment dur parce que parce
que même au sein de ma propre famille au
sein de mes propres amis enfin de mes
propres cercles d'amis vraiment je sens
de la discrimination et du rejet en
france on a la chance de pouvoir en tout
cas maintenant bientôt ce sera plus
calme et de pouvoir faire des tests
antigènes gratuitement mais bientôt ce
sera plus le cas et si non et sinon ces
vaccins ont rien à f au moins des fois
quand je sors avec des amis me disent tu
as ton test là parce que pas vacciner
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une casse
les pieds quartz et que c'était dur
d'avoir un avis tranché sur le vaccin
après je me suis construit entre autres
grâce à des vidéos mais pas que
et donc moi j'ai fait le choix de me
vacciner et sauf que dans mon entourage
proche donc ma mon père est un de mes
frères sont plutôt un peu réac alors pas
anti vaccins mais en tout cas on t'y pas
sanitaire et du coup voilà est en fait
souvent la discussion a été un peu
compliqué moi je voulais bien être
justement dans la discussion et avec mon
père le ton monte et en fait il faisait
des monologues et s'énerver tout seul
tellement ils étaient en colère de tout
ce qui se passait donc avec mon père
c'était clair je lui ai dit que je
voulais plus qu'on en parle et que je
respecte son choix mais qu'ils devaient
respecter le mien mais voilà ça va faire
des fractures dans les événements entre
admis et c est après tout ça c'est un
peu compliqué à gérer et je trouve que
le plus compliqué dans tout ça c'est
d'avoir son avis de réussir à se se
créer son propre avis et ne pas trop
être influencé par la vie des autres et
j'ai eu mon avis des fois du jour au
lendemain il change un petit peu salée
cyrus je suis institutrice dans une
école hors contrat à en charente c'est à
dire c'est une école primaire qui n'est
pas dépendant de l'éducation nationale
et cette année on a reçu une maman qui
voulait inscrire son fils en cm2 parce
qu'il avait de grandes difficultés dans
une école classique notamment français
de grandes lacunes au niveau de
l'écriture et de la lecture et ou ce
genre de petites écoles à petits
effectifs permet de rattraper ce genre
de lacunes et de bien le préparer au
collège et donc au moment de
l'inscription lui donne les papiers où
elle nous les ramène le lendemain avec
une page qui n'est pas signé c'est la
page d'autorisation d'hospitalisation en
cas d'urgence
donc en nous expliquant qu' elle ne
souhaite pas que son enfant
soit puisse aller à l'hôpital parce
qu'elle croit que il sera vacciné
d'office s'il y va et elle est contre la
vaccination et aux conséquences de ça on
a été obligé de refuser l'inscription si
elle ne pouvait pas signer cette page
donc privant son enfant de la
possibilité de dead et de soutien
scolaire en vue du collège voilà
c'était mon plus moi ce qui m'embête un
peu plus c'est quand je vois mon père
qui lui la retraite donc il reste très
souvent sur les chaînes d'information
type bfm tv qu'il a répète très très
souvent la même chose et qu'ils ont même
tendance à dramatiser les choses lui il
en a pris une peur bleue de cette
épidémie ça fait un an et demi que avec
mes frères on n'a plus le droit de
l'approcher il veut pas qu'on ait de
contact physique avec lui donc je suis
d'accord l'épidémie est encore là il
faut continuer d'en parler des gens
continuent à en mourir il faut pas les
dédramatiser tout ça mais les personnes
qui sont anti vax les personnes qui sont
contre le masque l ont pas changé d'avis
entre temps donc je vois pas pourquoi la
majorité de personnes qui suit toutes
ces nouvelles règles pour justement de
se protéger de l'épidémie doivent subir
constamment un bombardement
d'informations qui sont les mêmes depuis
un an et demi c'est lassant et c'est
c'est pesant sur le moral salut cyrus
j'ai 17 ans je vais étudier à bordeaux
en biologie et je vais garder mon prénom
pour moi donc dans mon cas le
le vaccin sur tout ça a provoqué
quelques désaccords avec une partie de
ma famille toutes nos parties par ten
paternel en fait parce que moi tout ce
qui est le vaccin et ch et un peu
comment dire je pense qu'on nous dit pas
tout qu'on sait pas trop mais que dans
tous les cas
quand on pèse le pour et le combo mieux
se faire vacciner que que non en fait
plutôt que d'attraper le qu'ovide bout
d'un moment je trouve que l'on peut plus
trop se faire son avis déjà par la
manipulation des informations les faits
que muse puis même sans parler de faits
que muse il y en a on qui sont censés
être des fakes news mais on sait pas
trop s'il est si on manipule les
chiffres
si on nous ment voilà puis même au delà
de ça c'est à dire que ça divise les
populations il ya ceux qui veulent se
faire vacciner ceux qui veulent pas
quand t'es pas d'accord
basse et plus ont discuté en
s'engueulant je sais plus trop s'il faut
que je crois mes proches ou un mec qui
est qui fait des vidéos philosophique
sur youtube
c'est de croire toi même fêté recherche
et tout va chercher l'information le
plus à la source possible et c'est donc
cette année à quartz est proche mais un
mec qui paie des visées de philo
solution après si tu fais vraiment ça
c'est que tu crois quand même un mec le
philosophe youtube donc dans tous les
cas un peu bloquée
yossi rice j'ai 17 ans je suis au lycée
du coup pour l'instant j'ai encore le
pass mais dans plus trop entendu coup je
me suis clairement fait vacciner juste
pour le pass parce que dire à voix haute
je suis avec ce n'est juste pas vacciner
tous à 13,1 me vaccine pour pas avoir
dire à voix haute je ne suis pas vacciné
je suis serveurs et je me suis mangé une
vie feu dans clients parce qu'il n'avait
pas son pass sanitaire est gelée refusé
de servir voilà
moi je sais russe merci beaucoup de nous
laisser nous exprimer je voulais juste
parler du sujet sur les dérèglements
hormonaux qui ont provoqué les vaccins
pour te rassurer je suis totalement pro
vaccin je me suis fait vacciner dès que
j'ai pu
au mois de mai simplement il y a eu
énormément de
de retour en fait sur des personnes
qui ont subi des dérèglements hormonaux
ce n'est pas des choses graves c'est
seulement que en fait on aurait bien
aimé avoir une communication pour pas
être inquiété quand ben ont toutes les
femmes ont eu des cycles perturber ou
alors des femmes ménopausées qui en vue
des deux nouveaux des règles après
plusieurs années de ménopause ou alors
des personnes avec des traitements
hormonaux comme des personnes
transgenres qui ont de nouveau la règle
je pense que il aurait été bien qu'il y
ait une communication officielle là
dessus afin de rassurer tout le monde
puisque ça n'est pas grave mais c'est un
effet secondaire très très juste et sans
j'en parlais avec une pote et je trouve
ça fou parce que dans toutes mes
recherches et c'est sur ça je l'aï
appris après alors fais mes vidéos alors
de mémoire donc effectivement ce pas
grave et ce n'est pas lié qu'au vaccin
du co lead là tout de suite j'ai un peu
pris de court parce que je n'avais pas
pensé à cette question là je vous mets
dans la description
quelques lignes qui explique un petit
peu plus en détail ce qui se passe
avec le vaccin et ses conséquences là
pour vous instruire ou vous rassurer
j'ai purement et simplement supprimé mon
compte facebook après plus de dix ans
passés dessus en fait l annonce le
planétaire à faire gros raz-de-marée
avec des pour des contres ça y'a pas de
problème j'accepte j'accepte ça mais ce
que j'ai pas qu accepter c'est voir la
comparaison du poste à lithaire à
l'étoile jaune déjouer devoir parler de
dictature
alors que c'était juste une solution
pour essayer de se sortir de cette cette
merde dans laquelle on a actuellement en
fait je voulais pas commencer à à ne
plus apprécier avoue avoir un regard
différent sur 7 sur ses proches autour
de moi
je comprends je vais commenter ce bocal
que j'ai construit avec un merci parce
que c'est vrai que c'est un sujet qui
divise beaucoup et que justement se
rendre compte qu'on n'est pas celle là
dedans et que ben en fait il se passe la
même chose dans chaque foyer
un peu ça peut apporter un appartement
de regroupement qui est vraiment
nécessaire enfin j'ai l'impression en ce
moment parce que ouais ce qui découle ça
c'est vraiment de la dissolution un peu
de la division en tout cas parce que
quoi que tu fasses tu seras jugé d'une
part ou d'une autre et je trouve que
c'est difficile en tout cas mon échelle
l'assumé à 100% ses choix et d'assumer
ceux des autres et c'est vraiment triste
de voir que pas en fait on devrait être
un peu une dent dans cette crise je sais
pas déjà que seulement spa où on n'a pas
pu voir des gens pendant longtemps et
c'est
dans notre propre foyer ca / - exemple
ma mère l'est pas vaccinés et mon père
mais la pression est bon
j'ai pas encore fixé à mon avis là
dessus mais au bout d'un moment chacun
aussi responsable de son corps et je
pense que on a tous besoin d'avoir ce
jugement permanent sur nous on n'est pas
tranquille on n'est pas tranquille nulle
part en fait ça à part seul avec toi
même tu aura jamais un instant on va pas
de la question et toi t'es chase co lead
etc etc et je pense que fin moi ça me
vient juste de passer une journée sans y
penser ou vous donne en eut en fait on
commence enfin - ça commence vraiment à
me peser à devenir lourd et ce serait
cool que s'arrête saga cyrus alors moi
le quid en plus de m'avoir fait perdre
partiellement le goût et l'odorat depuis
plus d'un an il a aussi failli me faire
perdre la relation que j'ai avec ma
maman c'est à dire que l'on a eu la plus
grosse dispute de toute notre vie à
cause des débats que vous contre le
vaccin j'ai 21 ans ma mère est
infirmière etc en se renseignant qu'elle
est tombée sur des articles et des
informations très alarmante concernant
la sécurité du vaccin provenant de
groupes anti vaccins très actif et très
présent sur beaucoup de plateformes
cément saga à l'armée et c'est encore
plus renseignés et elle a fini par
adhérer complètement à ces groupes anti
l'accent problème c'est que pour partir
en erasmus j'avais besoin de me faire
vacciner et le savait et à partir de là
j'étais persuadé que j'allais rires donc
elle était prête à tout pour m'ont
empêché avait tellement peur pour moi
qu'elle ne mangeait plus et dormait
presque plus et regardez même plus
attaquées avec nous le soir parce
qu'elle passait des heures dans sa
chambre a essayé de trouver l'article
qui allait me faire changer d'avis quand
elle a appris que je m'étais vacciner
sans lui dire elle l'a mal pris très mal
pris et arrêter de me parler de ces
histoires ça a eu un impact sur ma
relation avec ma mère la relation
qu'elle a avec le reste de ma famille
potentiellement l'éducation de mes
petits frères est aussi sur
l'intégrité de ma famille et l'emploi de
ma mère puisque aujourd'hui elle va sans
doute perdre son travail puisqu'elle ne
veut pas vaccinés qu'elle fait partie du
corps médical
donc les impacts vraiment réel celui-ci
russe moi ma mère elle coordonne tous
les centres de vaccination d'une ville
je ne citerai pas mais de plus de deux
cent mille habitants et et elle est
épuisée elle finit de bosser à la maison
à une ou deux heures du mat et bat déjà
c'est dur pour moi parce qu'elle est la
voir dans ce tête à la fin de fatigue
physique et morale
c'est vraiment compliqué pour moi mais
surtout beaucoup plus compliqué pour
elle parce que parce qu'il va pas tenir
quoi je sais qu'elle va pas tenir et et
en même temps tu as tous les
professionnels de santé tous les gens
tout le monde se repose sur elle pour
l'organisation parce que à dekian à des
quines merde elle elle arrive à réagir
sauf que là elle arrive à réagir mais
mais ça lui coûte je pense sur son sur
son état santé quoi donc voilà c'est
[Musique]
ça me touche et ce message
ben quoi bon courage à ta mère et merci
pour ce qu'elle fait en première année à
la fac à montréal et j'ai une amie
ses parents refusent qu'elles se fassent
vacciner alors que lé leurs envies et
la peur de se faire
de se faire mettre dehors de chez elle
donc je peux passer en vacciner et elle
peut pas avoir le post vaccinales
montréal et donc voilà pour
l'intégration à la fac c'est pas super
ça c'est dur ça salut cyrus je suis
étudiant jean parisienne j'ai 23 ans et
je voulais parler du cas de ma mère qui
est anti vax l'axé center n'a fait que
renforcer ce côté là en plus du côté
côté un peu complotistes autre que
l'anti vague et j'ai beaucoup moins
envie de rentrer la voir parce que j'ai
pas envie que toutes nos conversations
tournent autour de ce genre de sujet moi
je me suis vaccinée dès que j'ai pu
assez rapidement j'avais meadows début
juillet et en fait je n'ai pas dit que
j'étais vacciner tout de suite je lui
dis bien après j'avais pas envie de
prendre des réflexions désobligeantes en
voie de j'ai même pas ce que j'aurais pu
avoir mais en fait j'ai pas je n'avais
pas envie de risquer le truc et du coup
voilà je partage beaucoup moins avec ma
mère on se voit moins mais c'est la vie
j'espère que ça va s'arranger c'est
exactement le le coeur de
ce pourquoi je voulais faire cette vidéo
je crois salut suite je vais te raconter
du coup mon histoire qui est celle de ma
mère a mis deux mois donc on est
meilleurs amis depuis qu'on a huit ans
donc ça fait plus de dix sept ans qu'on
est potes on a tout fait ensemble
partager à peu près les mêmes idées et
puis voilà ça allait bien et il y a
trois ans elle a déménagé dans le sud
avec son son copain avec qui elle sort
depuis dix ans qui est aussi un ami à
moi mais c'est vrai que l a commencé à
partager ses idées qui étaient on va pas
se mentir
profondément radical
puis est arrivé vraiment cette année
avec bah voilà tous les confinements
tous les vaccins pas sanitaires etc
au point où en fait j'ai eu ma pote
téléphone et elle m'a dit qu'avec son
copain il voulait déménager en plus gary
parce que là bas on ne demandait pas le
vaccin ni de pas sanitaires et c'est que
ce n'était pas une dictature sanitaire
je cite évidemment comme
comme la france d'ailleurs ils sont
persuadés que macron pour la
présidentielle va changer la
constitution
pour être un dictateur
et
ça m'a perturbé pour la première fois de
ma vie je me suis dit que je n'arrivais
plus à leur dire des choses la politique
est beaucoup trop entrer dans leur vie
et ce à un point où je n'arrive même
plus à discuter avec eux par peur de les
perdre finalement la pandémie mort a
enlevé ma liberté de parole et prend
peut-être des amis bonjour moi je suis
vacciné je suis pro passé pro bac c'est
j'habite dans la région paca qui est la
région il ya le plus dans thiva
accédantes y passe et les conséquences
c'est que déjà au travail ils sont
quasiment tous anti vaccin anti passe
j'ai peur parce que j'ai peur de prendre
la maladie j'ai peur de ne pas être
accepté dans mon groupe et en même temps
l'autre conséquence que je vois c'est
que sur moi par exemple j'ai développé
une haine contre ces personnes contre
les personnes qui sont anti vaccin anti
passe comme s'il devait trouver un
coupable à la situation qu'on a
maintenant je vais 10,6 s'étaient tous
fait vacciner on ne serait pas là
aujourd'hui aurait pas le delta et tout
ça et je les déteste alors que j'ai
toujours essayé d'être quelqu'un de qui
se remet en question qui est raisonnable
qui ne juge pas sans savoir et tout ça
mais là je vois que c'est j'arrive pas
j'avoue qu'on peut être surpris parfois
denses ou danser contexte là
de nos propres réactions et même moi ça
m'arrivait genre des fois de me dire
mais
aussi russes c'est quand même fort là ce
que tu ressens contre cette personne par
rapport à un truc elle a dit par exemple
donc je comprends totalement moi ça se
passe en fait avec ma mère avec qui je
suis pas très proches de bases laissées
en discuter avec elle me suis rendu
compte que c'était impossible que peu
importe que je disais j'ai été un mouton
qui suivait le gouvernement
donc je le prends un peu personnellement
quoi mais ce qui m'a fait vraiment le
plus chez dans toute cette histoire
c'est de
pas être capable en fait d'accepter ce
que ma mère pense genre vraiment je la
reconnais plus du coup en vouloir
presque à ma mère alors que d'un vrai
c'est pas de sa faute quand on n'a pas
les même algorithmes
enfin du coup j'y repense à sa en
envoyant le documentaire bas avec sur
ton streams social dilemma et en fait ça
fait écho de ouf quoi genre
et après mais un texte qui je trouve est
encore plus fort et le débat nous
éloigner peut être encore plus que le
coc vis de lui même bonjour fille russe
alors moi je voulais témoigner par
rapport à ma demi soeur je n'ai pas
grandi avec j'ai jamais été proche
d'elle mais depuis quelques années ça
s'améliore parce que elle a trois
enfants je suis la marraine de sa fille
et du coup ça me faisait beaucoup du
bien de voilà de reprendre contact avec
elle sauf qu'avec l'épidémie a commencé
à partager hamas des articles non
sourcées complotistes anti-vaccins bref
la totale sur son compte facebook sans
conteste à tous les jours plusieurs fois
par jour j'imagine que je ne suis pas la
seule à avoir vécu cette sorte de
tension de non-dits autour de ce sujet
là et et qu'il ya beaucoup de famille
qui se déchire et moi je me dis que je
reprendrai plus contacter une fois que
tu feras tu as c'est parce que là je
n'ai pas envie de devoir confronter ma
propre soeur avec ses croyances en fait
ce n'est pas une personne ce soit mon
boulot
et voilà merci pour ce que tu fais merci
à toi merci pour ce témoignage coucou
cyrus j'espère que tu vas bien je vais
essayer d'être assez synthétique et de
répondre à ta question le coc vide et du
coup plus le vaccin ça a rapidement été
un sujet assez tabou dans ma famille est
dans mon entourage mais plus au niveau
de ma famille ça fait jouer justement la
science et la politique eu beaucoup un
amalgame si je peux dire là dessus je
pense entre la science et le
gouvernement qui du coup sont à séparer
selon moi et du coup je me suis retrouvé
dans une famille tu veux ou page avait
d'un côté mon papa qui était pas content
le vaccin pas pour non plus qui suivait
le mouvement on va dire et de l'autre
côté ma maman qui elle était par contre
anti vaccins mais anti anti vaccins du
coup je me suis retrouvé dans tout
intrus kouba en fait au-delà de la
question purs et durs du vaccin c'était
plus une question de un choix mais
j'avais l'impression de devoir choisir
entre papa maman quoi c'était oui mais
je vais en décevoir un il faut que je
plais à l'autre c'était vraiment quelque
chose d'assez compliqué parce que ben je
me retrouvais un peu le cul entre deux
chaises et je n'arrivais pas à savoir au
fond de moi ce que j'avais réellement
envie de faire finalement tout s'est
bien terminé
c'est le positif de cette histoire j'ai
une soeur en froid avec aucun de mes
parents et avec ma mère qu avec qui on a
eu des discussions à séoul aux à ce
sujet le principal en fait cessé de
parler c'est de communiquer et c'est de
parler ans pour soi et en son nom de pas
faire de projections sur la pensée de
l'autre de ne pas penser à la place de
l'autre ne pas faire de raccourcis parce
que en fait c'est là que commencent les
malentendus du coup voilà c'est mon
petit message à moi c'est que les oui en
fait le coc vide a fait que finalement
j'ai eu cette discussion avec ma mère et
j'ai pu approfondir ma relation avec ma
mère donc j'ai réussi à tirer du positif
de cette belle période la période
covidien n'est ce pas merci beaucoup et
je content que ça se passe mais acte
amer et merci pour ton témoignage je
pense que ça peut donner aussi beaucoup
d'espoir aux gens qui regardent cette
vidéo salut cyrus alors moi je vais te
parler des conséquences en fait négatifs
que la vaccination sur moi mon entourage
j'ai 18 ans est en fait très vite tous
mes potes sont fait vacciner très
rapidement parce que ben il n'avait pas
envie de ne pas sortir cet été et moi
pour d'autres raisons j'ai souhaité ne
pas me faire vacciner donc mon choix
était respecté il n'y avait pas trop de
problème avec ça le seul souci c'est que
je me suis
is à culpabiliser de ne pas être
vaccinés pour mes potes c'est à dire que
quand il allait au bar moi je pouvais
pas y aller du coup par solidarité mais
pat n'y allez pas donc adorable je les
adore mais moi je culpabilise et donc du
coup c'était horrible parce que il est
énorme mais c'est pas grave alors je
savais que ça allait souffler un peu et
moi j'étais là mère je me sens qu'on est
tous et pour autant je voulais rester
intègre à mes valeurs et à pourquoi je
le faisais pas et c'était horrible
horrible donc voilà
on a rarement ce point de vue
souvent les potes
paravent de bons potes
j'étais ému d'écouter vos nombreux
messages merci à toutes et à tous ça m'a
touché à la semaine prochaine
et suivez moi sur instagram aussi